Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Ben, Mark, James. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
Fresh assessment is in. Overall health went from 2.7 to 4.4. Every dimension improved, and the biggest gains landed on the three we deliberately targeted — trust, conflict, and commitment, each up two full points.
Sorry, can you say that last part again? You cut out for a second.
Sure — one sec.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Okay, works for me.
The airtime and dissent-timing stuff moved the most. The nudges did what I couldn't do by watching myself. My peak airtime went from two-thirds to about a third.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yeah, exactly.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
That matches what I was seeing on my end with community review and the advisory process.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Let's confirm in the channel.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Okay, works for me.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Makes sense to me.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay, works for me.
Good point — let's do that.
That tracks.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Good point — let's do that.
Just flagging that this touches the label renderer and the validator tests, so loop me in when it firms up.
Trust — same-day disclosure instead of four days. That's the one that felt personal.
Sure.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Right, that's what I meant.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to licensing and the ADR anyway.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Sure, I can own that.
Commitment — we didn't reopen the license question once this quarter. Or anything else, really.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the CARE governance framework anyway.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Just flagging that this touches licensing and the ADR, so loop me in when it firms up.
Makes sense to me.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
That's fair.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Agreed, let's capture it.
Can you scroll up to the top of that section?
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
How does this interact with the label renderer and the validator tests, if at all?
Sure — one sec.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Let's move to the next item.
I'll be the one to slow the celebration. Accountability is our new lowest at 4.0.
That's not a failure, but it's where to look next — let's keep peer feedback horizontal as the beta scales instead of sliding back to escalating everything to Dana.
Exactly right, and that's already the top recommendation in the new report. The loop worked because we treated the Q2 assessment as a mirror, not a target. We keep doing that.
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Just flagging that this touches licensing and the ADR, so loop me in when it firms up.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Okay, works for me.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Right, that's what I meant.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
That's fair.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Yeah, exactly.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
Makes sense to me.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Should I loop anyone else in on the community review and the advisory process side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on licensing and the ADR?
Question before we wrap — does any of this change what I'm doing on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Ben has the follow-up on the label renderer and the validator tests — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.